a trial that would have turned Fox
news's biggest stars into star Witnesses
the company will cut a 787.5 million
dollar check to Dominion voting systems
Fox was accused of knowingly airing
conspiracy theories and baseless claims
falsely linking Dominion to a scheme to
flip votes during the 2020 election
that's despite evidence including
internal messages in which Fox executive
Suzanne Scott warned challenging Trump's
bogus claims could hurt ratings today's
settlement
of
787 million five hundred thousand
dollars represents vindication
and accountability lies have
consequences and the settlement included
a public statement from Fox which
Tuesday night said it acknowledged the
Court's rulings finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false but there was
no requirement of an on-air apology or
retraction and fox attorneys declined to
speak to reporters outside the
courthouse